[Music]
on this sunday night serious accusations
claims of a kremlin scheme to install a
puppet regime in kiev there'll be very
serious consequences if russia takes
this move the deepening crisis and mixed
signals from a key ally
millions at risk in afghanistan they
cannot negotiate with the taliban the
controversial meeting to curb a
humanitarian catastrophe
radicalizing the next generation of
extremists it's called get them young
when you're young how the pandemic has
created a target-rich recruiting ground
and pervasive plastic it quite literally
is is everywhere the threat to the
planet and why activists say coordinated
action is crucial
[Music]
global national reporting tonight
sophie louie
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight in ukraine where the
rush to bolster its military is growing
more urgent the british government is
accusing the kremlin of plotting to
install a pro-russian leader in kiev and
says moscow has already chosen a
candidate that's fueling fears of an
imminent invasion with more than one
hundred thousand russian troops amassed
along the ukraine border mike locateur
has our top story
ukrainian soldiers patrol parts of a
forest outside donetsk tensions remain
high in the breakaway region along the
border with russia an area largely
controlled by pro-russian separatist
forces and they're likely to get even
higher uk intelligence officials claim
to have information indicating russia is
looking to install a pro-kremlin
government led by this former ukrainian
mp there'll be very serious consequences
if russia takes this move to try and
invade but also install a puppet regime
ukraine's ambassador to the uk wasn't
shocked by the leaked intelligence
report that's what i would expect as a
logical next step in russian invasion so
they will invade and will have to
establish some some sort of government
the politician at the heart of the
accusations scoffed at the idea
former ukrainian mp yevin
says he laughed at the story adding he
has been under russian sanctions since
2018 but he also said his country needs
new leadership
every voice matters meantime
pro-ukrainian demonstrations have popped
up around the world the u.s reiterated
its warning to russia if there is any
further russian
aggression in terms of sending russian
forces into ukraine there will be a
swift there will be a severe and there
will be a united response there are
questions about that solidarity because
we need russia against china the head of
germany's navy was forced to resign
after he said russian president vladimir
putin deserved respect and that keeve
would never win back annexed crimea from
moscow comments that could be cause for
concern according to matthew light an
associate professor of european russian
and eurasian studies i suppose the
suspicion remains that other people in
the german military or
high level physicians have similar views
or something more discreet about them
canada's support for ukraine has been
unwavering and in an interview on the
west block with mercedes-stevenson
defense minister anita anand hinted she
will be extending her troop deployment
in the region we do have a presence in
ukraine around ukraine and we will
continue to ensure our presence there
it's in my mandate letter i will be
delivering on it still some continue to
ask what more canada can do it's
expected prime minister trudeau will
face those questions when he meets the
media on monday
sophie
all right thanks for that michael cater
in ottawa well talks between western
allied governments and the taliban are
underway in norway as afghanistan's
humanitarian crisis deepens the
discussions will try to push the taliban
to keep its promises on human rights in
return for billions of dollars frozen
since the taliban took power but as mike
armstrong reports it's who is not at the
table that has critics condemning these
meetings
the afghan delegation that arrived in
norway saturday night is 15 members all
male it is the first time taliban
representatives have been on european
soil for talks since seizing power in
august negotiations are being held at a
resort northwest of the norwegian
capital norway is hosting but there are
delegations from the european union the
u.s the uk germany france and italy
[Music]
protesters were out in several cities
this was afghan nationals in the
norwegian capital there was also a
protest in downtown toronto they argued
that by hosting the talks norway is
legitimizing the taliban's control over
afghanistan
for us it's like saying yes to taliban
that norway want to say yes to taliban
the norwegian foreign minister has been
careful to say the talks are not
official recognition of the taliban
government but he says lines of
communication are needed because the
taliban is in effect governing the
country and millions face starvation
if norway says it's not legitimizing the
taliban the taliban itself says it's a
step to do exactly that
this type of invitation and
communication will help that's shocking
frieba razae was afghanistan's first
female olympian she now lives in
vancouver rezai says norway should have
insisted the taliban include women in
its delegation the meeting should have
been an opportunity to push the taliban
to open up they cannot negotiate with
the taliban at the cost of our rights
our human rights and women's
rights
the international delegations have said
humanitarian aid and human rights are at
the top of things to be discussed but
the taliban's main goal is very
different it wants access to close to 10
billion dollars frozen by the u.s and
other western countries it's time for
international community to support
afghans not punish them because of their
political disputes
now there are aid groups and some us
lawmakers saying action is needed even
if it means talking or negotiating with
the taliban the current stalemate has to
be broken they say
too many lives are on the line mike
armstrong global news
in northeastern syria the u.s led
coalition launched air strikes to help
end days of deadly clashes after a
prison break
[Applause]
tonight syrian democratic forces are
fighting for control of nearby
neighborhoods and the kurdish-run prison
where thousands of so-called islamic
state militants had been held the mass
escape happened thursday hundreds of
inmates have been recaptured but many
are still on the run hundreds of
transport truck drivers are convoying
across canada to protest a federal
vaccine mandate requiring them to be
immunized to travel back and forth over
the u.s border brittany rosen has more
on the rally and how this protest speaks
to the growing divide over how to handle
the pandemic
beginning in fort erie ontario a number
of trucks slow rolled their way to the
niagara region sunday morning this is
not just for the truckers
this is the backbone there they are the
backbone of canada
and the canadian and american good
friday
protests like these come as convoys
across the country are heading to ottawa
to oppose a vaccine mandate which
requires truckers traveling back and
forth across the u.s border to be
immunized against coba 19. sylvan
charles bois says the mandate is coming
at the wrong time he fears it will drive
up the price of consumer goods i think
we're at a point now
in in the pandemic that we need to
strike a more functional balance between
saving lives and keeping canadians fed
the latest pushback on vaccine mandates
from truck drivers draws a parallel with
canada's ongoing divide over public
health restrictions it prompts the
question as to whether policy is
matching the science rather than chasing
down the unvaccinated we should be
pushing our governments
to deal with the global health risk
that's in front of all of us bioethicist
carrie bowman believes the government
should focus on vaccinating the rest of
the world instead of the holdouts in
canada others such as dr isaac bogot say
policy makers shouldn't keep measures in
place longer than necessary whenever a
policy is being implemented i think we
have to ask ourselves what's the goal
here like what are you actually trying
to do both agree there should be
flexibility in how pandemic policy is
shaped in the future that's probably one
of the most important aspects
to question when you're making policy
and sadly i think sometimes that gets
lost brittany rosen global news toronto
south of the border confirmed covet
cases are finally starting to fall but
the drop in infections doesn't mean the
u.s is out of the woods hospitalizations
are plateauing in some areas but as
jennifer johnson explains they are
skyrocketing in parts of the west
thousands marched in the u.s capitol
denouncing mask and vaccine mandates as
the omicron variant makes its way across
the country almost a third of eligible
americans are still not fully vaccinated
less than half are boosted if you want
to get it you're more than welcome to
but the government should never tell me
that i have to get something ever but
it's the unvaccinated still filling up
hospitals and dying with an average of 2
100 deaths a day linked to coven 19. we
have the saddest stories you've ever
heard in your life of orphaned children
and dead mothers and people losing their
loved ones when they didn't have to
william adams regrets his decision not
to get vaccinated it brings you right to
the brink for
to tell yourself you don't want to live
while covert 19 cases are in a steep
decline on the east coast cases are
skyrocketing in parts of the west and
midwest every hospital is full so trying
to find a facility that has an open
space with the appropriate care
is difficult the white house coveted
response team says approval of a vaccine
for children five and under could come
next month but will take longer until
shots get into arms even if the fda were
to reconsider the approval of the
vaccine you're looking at a timeline
when this would get pushed at best
perhaps to into late march nearly one
million children tested positive for
covet last week many parents are
desperate for any shot or test they can
get my daughter had half her class out
last week which was very stressful i got
five close contact notifications for her
so the poor thing got tested six times
in one week the omicron variant is
crushing the country's labor market too
in early january almost 9 million
americans said they were not working
because they had covet 19 or were caring
for someone who was infected this is the
worst it's taking us out with it weekly
jobless claims jumped last week to their
highest level in three months an
indication the so-called great american
sick out from coven 19 continues to
sideline the country's workforce
jennifer johnson global news washington
beijing is tightening covet 19 controls
ahead of next month's winter olympics
roughly 2 million people living in an
area deemed high risk for infection have
been ordered to undergo mass screening
strict coveted measures are in place for
the olympics with the government hoping
to isolate athletes officials and
journalists from the outside world so
far 72 people arriving for the winter
games have tested positive for the virus
new zealand's prime minister canceled
her wedding today to keep in line with
covet 19 restrictions that go into
effect from midnight
as for mine my wedding will not be going
ahead but i just join
many other new zealanders who have had
an experience like that as a result
of the pandemic
jacinda ardern says new zealand will
move to a so-called red setting the
country's highest covet 19 alert level
under the restrictions people must wear
a mask wherever they go and gatherings
like weddings sporting events and
religious services are capped at 100
people
next on global national travelers
changing course how kovitt is driving
tourists to stick close to home
the pandemic has changed the way
canadians travel with restrictions
forcing many to stay local for their
vacations in ontario a new staycation
tax credit is even incentivizing a
holiday closer to home and as ann
gaviola reports it's a much needed
lifeline for the hospitality sector
it was devastating because i didn't want
to spend another summer in toronto i
wanted to get out of the city covid
canceled danielle orenda's three-week
trip to europe in 2020 this year she's
planning staycations if i can't taste
wine and tuscany i can do it right here
in ontario based on google searches
interest in staycations across canada
spiked the first week of january that's
when ontario's tax credit came into
effect the ontario government expects
nearly 2 million families to benefit
from this 270 million dollar program the
tax credit can be applied towards
accommodation within the province
whether that's a hotel a cottage or a
campground and it can apply to a single
trip or several
it will reimburse twenty percent of
accommodation costs of maximum claims of
a thousand per person two thousand per
family the hospitality industry says
it's a lifeline when many of the
businesses are on the brink financially
and emotionally dealing with changing
covet restrictions inflation and
struggling to find staff
they are frustrated they're angry
omicron has been more impactful
than anything else we've seen during
this pandemic
because they're tired while the pandemic
may be a terrible burden for some it's
been a boon to others
while folks are still generally staying
closer to home within like 500
kilometers of where they live they're
they're trying out new places ontario's
staycation tax rebate won't be
applicable towards many airbnb homes but
they've already benefited from the
staycation phenomenon the pandemic has
fueled interest in rural canada jurassic
prince edward county about two hours
east of toronto
there is world class
in our backyard and always has been and
shining a light on that in
kind of a tragic awful time for our
industry
has been kind of that blessing in
disguise after five years of renovations
the royal pickton hotel opened weeks ago
amid ever-changing covid restrictions
it's designed with staycationers in mind
i really believe it will help kick start
that tourism and hospitality economy the
hospitality industry says it may provide
a 30 boost to revenue but it took 22
months to get into this hole it'll be at
least another 22 months with support to
come out of it
and gaviola global news toronto
ahead in cell ideology how the dangerous
subculture is targeting the next
generation of extremists
virtual school and pandemic restrictions
have meant more screen time for many
young people across this country and
experts fear that could make them more
vulnerable to so-called incels men who
blame women and social standards for
their involuntary celibacy
as abigail beeman explains there are
concerns incels are targeting the next
generation of extremists online
it's an innocent enough search term
self-esteem for guys but type that into
youtube and within four clicks when
global news tried we were offered all
kinds of posts promoting hate including
one video about embracing the idea of
violence in a society that despises what
it means to be a man it's very
frightening how quickly
a young man who might be lonely or might
be troubled or might be seeking
information
can have
disinformation
and hateful ideology put in front of him
experts say it's a new trend in cell
communities targeting not just teenagers
but even boys online we've had several
people
ages of between the ages of 10 to 12
years old pandemic restrictions have
meant young people spending more time
online amplifying radicalization says
this expert who runs a de-radicalization
program for young canadian men and boys
in terms of recruitment strategy it's
called get them young when they're young
and indoctrinate them into these
ideologies
incels a concept still relatively new to
most canadians many learning about it
for the first time in the wake of the
2018 toronto van attack that left 11
people dead including nine women now
portals of overlapping hate misogyny
white supremacy the far right aren't
hard to find on social media chat rooms
and gaming platforms i think we are
collectively coming to that point where
we are asking you know if not demanding
that social media companies really do
rethink those algorithms
experts say there's no easy solution but
there is a push for social media giants
to evolve algorithms and to remove and
disincentivize extremist content not
allowing creators to make money through
such sites you can actually see the way
in which these algorithms on platforms
start putting more and more radicalizing
content in front of in front of young
men who may have gone simply seeking
information about self-esteem or dating
or fitness or weight lifting in a
statement youtube says it has taken
additional steps to ensure that those
who aim to spread violent extremist
ideology cannot do so although the
company did not respond to any specific
questions about incels
meta which operates facebook and
instagram tells global news it acts on
in-cell related content that breaks
platform rules though not everything is
clear cut and they're now working with
experts to better understand the
environment there's also the legislation
option both the united states and europe
are looking at regulations targeting
algorithms canada has promised new bills
aimed at social media with stiff
penalties if companies don't remove
online hate but the heritage minister's
office wouldn't comment on specifics or
exactly what comes next abigail beeman
global news ottawa
next the problem with plastic and the
push for a global treaty to reduce it
we are surrounded by plastic whether we
see it or not according to a new report
on the effects of plastic waste it's in
our food our air our water and if action
isn't taken soon on a global coordinated
scale activists warn plastic pollution
threatens the future of life on this
planet in much the same way as climate
change redmond shannon reports
the enduro river in kenya hidden beneath
a blanket of plastic bottles it is not
me who was shocked you know i think it
is the boys who are shocked to see the
rivers so polluted they couldn't see the
water i couldn't see the water in the
river on a plastic water activist james
wikibia has seen it all when it comes to
plastic waste his country banned
single-use plastic bags five years ago
with some success canada is looking to
do the same with bags and some other
single-use items like straws yeah indeed
the whole world is addicted to the
convenience of plastic bags and that is
where the problem is
i
don't think
people will die when they stop using
plastic bags in fact there are growing
concerns that if we don't cut back on
making plastic our health and the
planet's entire ecosystem could be at
risk plastics and their chemicals are
they're in the air they're in our food
they're in our water they're in our
honey i found it on the highest mountain
peaks and the deepest deepest ocean
trenches i mean it quite literally is is
everywhere a new report from the ngo the
environmental investigation agency
highlights in particular microplastics
broken down from larger items the
invisible particles make their way into
our food chain chemical additives in
some plastics have been linked to birth
defects and cancers the reality is that
in order to meet the scale of the crisis
at hand we can't just have individual
actions and we can't just have
isolated fragmented national policies
that target this and that and all
different in different countries at the
end of next month the united nations
environment assembly begins in kenya
with hopes for a binding treaty this
month more than 70 large companies that
sell plastics including coca-cola and
unilever called for an agreement that
reduces plastic production as well as
improving waste management likened and
linked to the issue of carbon emissions
solving this problem will require
fundamental changes to how we live our
lives redmond shannon global news london
and that is global national for this
sunday night i'm sophie louie tonight
your canada is this elk patiently
waiting to cross the street in canmore
alberta we would love to see your corner
of the country so please keep sending
your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching and have a great
night
[Music]